[Musique]
qu'elles soient mansarde soupente ou
trou à rats on les appelle des chants
des chambres de bonne même si les bonnes
qui se nomme maintenant les employés de
maison s'ils font de plus en plus rares
et ceux qui vivent ici sous les toits de
paris on les appelle quel que soit
l'état jeu réel où ils sont ni chez les
locataires du 6e parmi eux on trouve des
étudiants qui ne sont pas forcément des
violoncellistes on trouve des vieillards
on trouve des isolés et beaucoup
l'étranger mais on trouve aussi des
couples qui sont seulement des mal logés
oh
les locataires du 6e se sont ou des
provisoire ou des marginaux et bien peu
auront pour s'en sortir la possibilité
d'écrire des romans et comme père athir
elika vécu deux chambres de bonne en
chambre d'hôtel évite encore dans une
mansarde la chance de remporter le prix
féminin pour certains la chambre de
bonne cinévasion catastrophe pour un
étudiant par exemple pour des occupants
très jeune ça peut n'être qu'un début
la chambre de bonne ça peut être au
contraire une sorte de d'ouverture vers
la liberté
mais c'est plus tard si l'on reste dans
la chambre de bonne aussi ils ont échoué
quand on est dans des chambres de bonne
il y a quand même une des considérations
sociales de la part des des autres gens
de l'immeuble et on ne tolère pas que
dans les chambres de bonne en face du
bruit qu'on y vivent normalement que la
concierge c'est le gendarme pour pour
les gens du sixième ou du 7e et c'est
elle qui fait le kif et les commissions
qui dit attention bruit attention vous
avez déranger telle personne qui est la
locataire
on a vraiment l'impression d'être sous
habitants absolument on est à la fois on
est un peu coupés du monde à cause de la
hauteur parce que on n'a pas
l'impression d'être un locataire normal
déjà et d'autre part on est en vie on
vit de façon un peu écartée dans une
chambre de bonne
on y lave les choses dans un petit dans
une petite ou une petite cuvette soi
même on ne peut pas n'est pas question
d'installer une douche ou des choses
vous n'avez jamais eu douch avoue non
non non hélas dans l'appartement de du
xiiie arrondissement vous allez avoir un
oui au mieux une pièce trois pièces
c'est fatigant c'est fatigant par la
[Musique]
voix et on se voit c'est du bo9 à l'âge
où est-ce que vous l'achetez donne on
donne on y achète pas jeuland à la rue
du cherche midi tous les jours vers la
forêt bien au niveau des caisses de
quelle saveur bien cherché la petite
chaîne a monté ce matin du lapin avec du
riz elle est jalouse à bord champ oui
elle est ma vez comme une teigne ya
combien de temps que vous êtes ici à
julie ces gens ce pas vous le dire comme
iliad indique la circulaire du 18 ans et
j'en ai 76
il avait eu un fiancé patrie en fait
c'est énorme
enfin c'est comme ça la vie encore que
me plains pas maintenant elle ma place
face à mes vieux jours je suis pas
malheureux mais j'ai connu vous savez
j'ai lutté je suis pas arrivé comme ça
moi elle est d'abord les députés dans la
brochure dans le livre on rit on
travaille aux pièces étaient mal payés
vous savez c'est nul et puis alors j'ai
eu la chance de rentrer au journal
officiel quelqu'un me a fait rentrer
parce qu'on remonte pas comme ça dans
ces maisons là
alors là jamais le gagner ma vie mais
c'était dur vous savez fallait partir à
4h30 du matin elle va tomber
on ne va pas tomber année par bayt sopi
ya là de l'asean
mais pour mes noël mange pas en ce
moment c est comment vous avez connu
madame comment vous êtes connus je ne
sais pas les béjaouis par les pigeons
par les pigeons des femmes le bison les
chantiers chez altis à la banque leur
savez c'est pas c'est pas bien drôle v2
seul mais à côté de crm encore mieux que
d'être placé dans une maison de retraite
autant rester chez soi pourtant et c'est
dans sa mansarde chez soi parce que vous
faites ce que vous voulez non en
communauté comme ça en dortoir ça ne va
pas c'est vrai ça va vous avez pas des
gens qui vous aident sur le palier qui
met une condition au nom là l'iphone ne
faut pas penser j'en ai
en face elle voit un poison sel elle m'a
insulté le culte sommes jamais rien fait
je propose de ses malheurs pas
puisqu'elle est cool on m'a mise en lui
avec des émanations a coûté elle allait
être malade un peu cela peut-être un peu
malade et puis vous savez faut compter
sur personne si nous nous tous si bien
voyez-vous quand on est en voisines et
par des hommes en émule qu'avec des
femmes qui vont donc un service
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis américain je vienne de la ville
de détroit
mes parents tiennent un petit magasin je
suis venu à paris il ya cinq ans pour
faire du mime
je faisais mes études pendant quatre ans
et maintenant pour gagner de l'argent je
donne au théâtre pour enfants et puis je
donne des cours d'anglais j'ai fait des
traductions de temps en temps ces
structures là ses portes à lisez aussi
les vents qui ont fait quelque chose
non je ne vends pas ces deux c'est trop
fragile pour vendre oui mais c'est une
espèce de recherche dont je n'ai pas
encore compris moi même je sais toujours
de comprendre pourquoi je les fais parce
que je les fais avec mon intuition il en
passe des journées entières des semaines
entières te faire que ça je fais
beaucoup de choses manuel des habs jour
ma table je vais à faire une chose et
puis je me retrouve un petit peu là
dedans je veux dire que je m'approche
plus de moi même mais tout en sachant
pas très bien ce que ce que je fais je
me sens ici ou bien je vis avec une
fille qui est qui et françaises qui est
israélienne israélienne s'appelle comme
ça il est à elle seule question est
qu'est ce qu'elle fait et lebron ici à
paris elle est bonne chez les gens elle
est placée chez les gens ça c'est
violent c'est pas marrant voilà oui bien
sûr alors comment est ce que tu te
débrouilles financièrement
si je compte mon loyer je dois déjà
trois mois et demi de loyer alors
éditoriale est propriétaire non il est
très gentil avec moi là j'ai beaucoup de
la chance ça ici je dois dire que je
suis assez bien parce que j'ai eu une
chambre qui n'est pas vraiment très très
petit mais à 2 c c'est un formidable
et puis en hiver il fait très froid
il ya des fissures leur galère qui vient
et qui va on peut se permettre de vivre
pauvres ici en france ou en europe mais
l'amérique non si je vivais comme ça
l'amérique se sera pas possible parce
que parce que sa pauvreté ressort d'une
façon qui n'est pas très soutenable
parce que la bad est très pauvre ce
c'est quelque chose qui regardaient
comme partout bien je veux dire la
qualité des gens là bas est quand même
sur l'argent et ce qui nous arrive
d'avoir des inquiétudes sur ton avenir
non oui
un gain qui est ou non je me pose
beaucoup de questions ça a sans arrêt
mais je m'en inquiète pas tellement non
finalement non je vous ai je de leur
propre style à la fois j'ai la france ça
je crois que ça va ça va s'arranger
parce que maintenant je cherche je sors
tu as plutôt de la confiance c'est ça la
confiance ça mais c'est normal je trouve
que c'est normal
j'ai 26 ans je suis jeune et je le sens
alors à 26 ans passe à plein de trous si
j'avais 45 ans et j'étais encore russie
alors là c'est autre chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur moment ça va c'est quand il
y en a qui sont là ils s'énervent là
dedans on est toujours en train de
bananes ouvrier tourneur il gagne 90
mille francs par mois elle en gagnait 50
milles avant la naissance de leur petite
fille comme femme de ménage
depuis neuf ans qu'ils sont arrivés la
martinique
ils vivent dans cet unique pièce de
médecins quand sur 3 mètres et sur les
murs hiver qui ruisselle australie les
retourner dans leurs îles retrouver leur
soleil bien sûr mais ils veulent d'abord
faire des économies gagner ici un magot
pour rentrer au pays sans hôte et voici
jacqueline une beauté du quartier
clignancourt
elle a 18 ans et son mari 26 une
mansarde de coeur un bébé et l'eau
courante ils ont bricolé eux mêmes en
cachette mais qui s'écoule faute de
tuyauterie dans un seau
oh ça redonne de loin je n'ai d'avoir 16
ans et plus haut comme tous les jeunes
gel à la fête foraine gelé connu la fête
foraine les imprimeurs imprimer depuis
des années d'avoir 14 15 ans je crois
ces imprimeries vite oublier que c'est
lui les conducteurs comme tous les maris
il faut quand même pas exagérer le soir
quand ils rentrent au pays des roches et
7 6 8 6
why can't we très bas oui parce que par
une journée de boulot je comprends quand
même mon mari surtout dans l'est dans le
bruit dans l'imprimerie c'est quand même
débrouillé mais enfin il n'y a pas
opposé à ce que vous voyez vos anciennes
copines et tout ça tous les jours des
amis du quartier vauban non meilleur
face à lui si je dis bon ben j'ai causé
à quelqu'un ça ne plaît pas mais ce
qu'il pense quand même que j'ai été
traîné où il ya eu c'est vrai je vends
cause pas si vous demande ce que vous
avez fait dans la journée
non non il me demande pas non c'est moi
n'est pas julie tient aujourd'hui
j'étais là j'ai j'ai vu ceux ci
il espère quand même ce que je fais
gaffe à ce que je savais moi je chez moi
je suis bien chez moi alors je les sens
et la volta non je rage à kiev
[Musique]
la même envie
vous êtes content ça va surprendre sa
bonne foi et d'autres chroniqueurs vous
êtes content de parler il faut voir
chargé dire ça vous ennuie pas de plus
et deux garçons n'ont pas du tout voici
habitude il faut bien voir pourquoi vous
avez du mal à vous habitez bon mais ça
change un peu
vous n'avez pas envie de quand même de
vous à grandir un peu
pas envie d'avoir un réfrigérateur
d'avoir des trucs comme ça oui je vais
lire ici non mais je veux dire changer
et d'éventuels moral avant tout les
sujets bien tourné au moins six mois
avant de trouver ça aussi moins six mois
et puis on au monde et ont commencé à
c'est bien simple depuis janvier que je
cherchais justement s'attarder centre
janvier je cherchais je cherchais à
trouver sa fin juillet mais joue sur le
jour où j'ai trouvé ça beau croyez moi
j'en ai pleuré
j'étais vraiment content parce que de
vivre chez ma mère ma mère est bien
gentil mais il faut quand même qu'elle
allait lever tous ces gosses alors le
jour où images ils ont bousillé un
deuxième au fond que n'importe quoi
il faut absolument changer comment vous
y prenez mon dieu comme m on mettra un
mag
[Musique]